- [Interviewer] Are you a Kanye West fan?
- I love Kanye!
I'm mad at him always!
We're always kind of in a fight in my head
but once I hear his music I'm back.
(upbeat dubstep music)
- Kanye West returned to Twitter
and at the same time announced
that he was going to be writing a philosophy book.
So,I decided to go around the office
and see if people could tell the difference,
between a real Kanye West tweet and a fake Kanye West tweet.
And see if anybody would, actually,
buy a philosophy book from Yeezy.
Are you mad at Kanye West?
- Mildly.
- Ye said, that he is going
to be printing out a philosophy book.
Did you hear that?
- Oh wow, that makes sense.
- He said he's writing the book
through these tweets on Twitter.
- So the tweets are the book?
- The tweets are the book.
- So, we're gonna play a game
where I'm gonna read you quotes
of some of Kanye's, some that aren't, and you need to say
if it is a real Kanye tweet or a fake Kanye tweet.
^If you wanna see the true character of a person,
^watch how they treat someone who can't do anything for them.
- I'm gonna go with Ye only because
on the songs, he's always referencing, like,
family members or people around him,
who really don't mess with him
or ask him what he's doing unless they want something.
So, I'm gonna say Ye.
- Ooo, I kinda like that, but I will say it's a nay.
- I'm gonna say that it is a real Kanye tweet.
- Ooh, correct.
(Bell dings)
- That's a real Kanye quote, for sure.
- That's correct. (bell dings)
- Not Kanye.
- No, not Kanye?
- Definitely, Kanye West. (buzzer sound)
^Most people fail in life because they major in minor things.
^- Fuucckk, that's deep.
^- Right! That's good.
- That sounds like a DJ Khaled tweet.
(laughing)
- Real Kanye tweet.
- Kanye?
- Ehnt. (buzzer sound)
(laughing)
- Tony Robbins.
- Really?
- Yeah.
^We believe time is a man made construct.
^Actually, time and money are both man made currency,
^because you can spend them both.
- I don't think that's Kanye.
- It was a little verbose.
- Yeah, I was gonna say wordy.
- Wordy.
- Wordy?
- So, probably...
- Kanye.
- Probably, Kanye.
- That is not a Kanye quote.
(wrong answer buzzer sound)
- That's a real Kanye quote.
- Oh my gosh...
(laughing)
...this game is stupid.
- Kanye?
(bell dings)
- Damn, you got it!
- Ha ha!
^- You were not born on earth to please anyone;
^you have to live life to express yourself;
^not to impress someone.
- Sounds like Kanye.
- Yeah, I'll say yeah.
- Wrong! (buzzer sound)
- I'm gonna go 'head and say that's Yeezy.
- (chuckles) No.
- Damn.
- It sounds like it would be.
- That sounds like Yeezy.
- Would you buy a philosophy book by Kanye West?
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah?
- Yeah. I'm assuming it's gonna have dope artwork in it.
- Yeah.